There's an old psychoanalytic idea,
which is really worthwhile.
It's like a surgical tool.
And I would say if you're going to use
it in your own life,
use it carefully because you don't want
to do unnecessary surgery.
And the rule is,
and I think this is union rule,
but I can't remember exactly where I
read it.
If you can't understand why someone is
doing something,
look at the consequences of their
actions,
whatever those might be.
And then in further motivation from the
consequences.
So if you see someone who seems to be
doing nothing except making everyone
around them and themselves miserable and
you can't understand why,
one of the hypotheses that you might
entertain is that they're trying to make
everyone around the miserable as well as
themselves.
And that's actually their goal.
And it's hard for people to understand
these sorts of things because when we
see phenomena like the columbine
shooters,
you know,
we always assume that the reason that
these people are doing these sorts of
things is for other reasons.
Then the reasons they,
that the reasons that appear to motivate
them or even the reasons they say
they're doing it because the columbine
killer,
especially the more literate one,
he said exactly why he was doing what he
was doing.
It's not,
it's as clear as it could possibly be.
All you have to do is go online and read
what he said and he tells you what he
was up to.
But people don't like to think that way
because they don't believe that anybody
could be consciously possessed of that
much malevolence without there being
some other kind of cause.
Like,
you know,
he was bullied at school or you know,
he was an outcast and those things were
only vaguely true and they certainly
weren't more true of having them.
They were true of,
you know,
how many people in high school or you
know,
bullied and somewhat outkast.
Jesus,
it must be 10%.
It's probably more like 30 you know,
that doesn't mean that the schools are
blowing up all over,
you know,
all over all the time.
It's a completely insufficient
explanation.